sí
[Música]
ya es oficial hace un par de días se
confirmó el remake de resident evil 3 y
es todo lo que esperamos y más y ver si
tiene nariz bueno tal vez no todo
ming
desde el estreno de resident evil 2
remake que resultó siendo un juegazo
personalmente para mí el ghost y estaba
entre ración nivel 2 y red dead
redemption no es que se quiero fueron
mal juego es genial de hecho sólo que
estos dos son unas finalidades de juego
el punto desde que se estrenó lo único
que me han estado esperando los fans más
acérrimos de esta franquicia era la
inevitable revelación del remake del
siguiente juego dado que ya de por sí
habían algunas pistas en el mismo juego
que apuntan a que ya están trabajando en
él y en el estadio play de hace unos
días
capcom lo ha vuelto a hacer y nos engañó
contrario sorpresas de resident evil 3
con la secuencia inicial de primera
persona y luego la revelación de lo que
en realidad querían mostrarnos el
tráiler nos enseña personajes ya
conocidos sus nuevos diseños algunos
lugares más reconocidos de la obra
original y algunas cosas más en unas
alucinantes secuencias que nos dieron
nostalgia a todos abril de 2020 fue la
fecha escogida por capcom para
lanzamiento de este juego pero vamos a
ver igual que el vídeo anterior que dice
sobre reciente ball todo lo que sabemos
hasta el momento de este nuevo título
comenzamos con lo que ya sabíamos desde
mi vídeo anterior el equipo de capcom
por lo menos hasta ahora decidió quitar
el subtítulo en némesis al videojuego
haciendo que se titule y tan solo
resident evil 3 además de eso por lo que
sabemos por los trailers que se lanzaron
del título y el aún contará con la
mecánica de evasión que tenía en el
juego original dado que en redes de
nivel 2 esta mecánica aún no existía e
igualmente que el juego anteriores que
aseguró que el presidente ball 3 aún se
tendrá las mismas mecánicas de conseguir
y mejorar armas
algo que muchas personas han estado
diciendo es que les molesta que resisten
thibault 3 todos prestados muchos de los
modelos o escenarios del remake del
segundo juego lo cual es algo ridículo
claro que este nuevo juego usará algunos
escenarios del remake anterior ya que si
recordamos pues este nivel 3
originalmente ocurre parcialmente antes
de los eventos de wars de nivel 2 así
que vamos a visitar zonas ya conocidas
como la comisaría pero también tendremos
muchísimas zonas nuevas
y si al parecer también este puzzle
estará incluido [ __ ]
cabe también tener en cuenta que por lo
que parece este juego será más corto que
el remake del segundo título pero es
algo normal ya que el remake del 2
cuenta con dos campañas separadas este
juego cuenta sólo con la campaña
principal hay algunos sitios que
aseguran que la campaña durará solamente
5 horas es decir la mitad de la campaña
de brasil a nivel 2 pero yo creo que
esto es pura especulación es verdad que
la campaña han rescindido el 3 original
era más corta que el anterior pero al
igual que hicieron con el remake del año
pasado va a haber muchas zonas y
aspectos de este juego que re creen y
tal vez creen nuevas zonas para que la
campaña resulte siendo mucho más larga y
entretenida fuera de todo esto lo poco
que nos dio a conocer el tráiler y la
información filtrada son los modelos
renovados de los personajes y de con un
aspecto más actual
carlos sí es bastante distinto pero al
menos su caballera le da personalidad
nikoláy y todos los que pudimos ver en
el tráiler sean espectaculares con el
motor gráfico usado escenarios en
relucientes y llenos de vida bueno vida
en este mismo trailer pudimos ver algo
que está causando revuelo entre los fans
que les gusta a teorizar ya que en este
trailer hay una parte en la que él se ve
a un espejo y parece alucinar con su
reflejo lo cual lado a pensar los fans
que tal vez en este juego simplemente la
mecánica de las alucinaciones que ya es
saber los que vieron mi vídeo anterior
se suponía que iba a ser desarrollada
para el octavo juego no sabe nada más de
esto y nadie de capcom ha hablado al
respecto pero sí hay que admitir que
estas secuencias son extrañas pero quién
sabe tal vez solo fue una broma de parte
de capcom
bueno hablemos del verdadero
protagonista del juego
némesis si en el juego anterior te
estresa hoy te avanzada que mister x te
persiguiera todo el tiempo
en este juego créeme que la vas a pasar
mal porque némesis es como un star x con
esteroides y armas
ya que él te estará persiguiendo y será
implacable ya que cuenta con armas un
lanzacohetes y estará detrás de ti la
mayor parte del juego gritando stores
por todo el lugar a pesar de que en el
tráiler no lo vimos ni lo escuchamos ya
sabemos cómo sonará ya que una demo
especial de resident evil 2 remake
lanzada hace poco si salimos de la
comisaría habrá una zona en donde
escucharemos a némesis persiguiendo a
alguien tal vez allí o diciendo su
famosa línea
ahora imagínense ese sonido todo el
tiempo detrás de ustedes como mencioné
antes anime si no lo vimos en el tráiler
más que unos breves segundos pero que si
lo pudimos ver fue en filtraciones e
imágenes promocionales donde se ve
parcialmente es un nuevo diseño bueno
aquí sí hay que hablar bastante name
existe un diseño bastante característico
hemos visto ya bastantes veces pero esto
es algo distinto primero y lo que más me
llamó mi la atención es que no sé si
estoy viendo mal o es tal vez un error
pero veo que némesis ahora tienen
henares lo cual tal vez una estrategia
diseño para que parezca más humanizado o
algo pero no lo sé es bastante extraño
aparte de eso no logró de los tentáculos
que sobresalían de su cuello en el juego
original y ahora sólo unos tubos
conectados o algo en su pecho no lo sé
tal vez no contenga su corazón y su ropa
se ve algo extraño ya que son pequeñeces
pero némesis de la cara del videojuego
aún más que yo cualquier personaje y
verlo distinto como lo recordaba extraño
pero confío en que sea como sea se verá
extraordinario en el juego final ustedes
qué opinan
ah
esa es toda la información que tenemos
hasta ahora de este juego se ha revelado
hace poco y no es mucho lo que puede
averiguar pero ya con esto podemos
hacernos una idea de cómo será este
nuevo remake los invito a todos a
seguirme en twitter donde subiré más
información del juego en cuanto sepan
más filtraciones por momento quisiera
saber qué piensan ustedes de este nuevo
juego que ya se aproxima para el próximo
año amigo personal resentido 3 es el
juego que más me gustó de los tres
originales creo que lo llegue a
completar como cuatro veces no lo sé y
verlo no de esta manera al igual que él
recibe ánimos del año pasado me llena de
ilusión no puedo esperar para jugarlo de
mi parte eso ha sido todo por ahora si
pasa algo más ya les informaría hasta la
próxima
i
[Música]
sé que ustedes no lo saben porque no
pueden saberlo no me ven pero acá en la
zona donde yo grabo ahí cerca pulidoras
talleres un montón de cosas así que tú a
lo que me estresa o grabando este vídeo